welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a no spoiler review of
the Marvels the 2023 Marvel Studios team
up film with Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers Monica Rambo and Kamala Khan
directed by Nia Casta and the movie that
the Marvel fandom and the media have
decided holds the entire fate of the
franchise in its glowing bangled hands
I've been fascinated to see how Marvel
Studios has shifted its marketing from
this movie being a wacky beasty boy
scored triple handcuff goof around to
with Marvel's final trailer this week a
high stakes Adventure level threat with
cameos and tie-in to the growing
Multiverse so with all of this confusing
Marketing in this review I'm going to
explain what to expect from this
Marvel's film my thoughts on these
Marvel post-mortems going around and I'm
going to do something I've always been
terrified to do and rank the Marvels
compared to the other MCU Titles since
2021 no Major Spoilers in this video
beyond what Marvel has revealed in their
own marketing but if you want to go in
completely blind proceed at your own
risk okay let's start with my Topline
headline review here is what I tweeted
upon walking out of the theater last
night and my quote got picked up by
variety so I guess it's newsworthy but I
stand by what I said the Marvel's is an
astonishingly wacky film I had a lot of
fun Iman volani was born to be an MCU
star she elevates a tangled story into a
Marvel nerd's dream sometimes that dream
waivers out of syn but it sticks The
Landing I enjoy the Marvels more than
the 2019 Captain Marvel film but I think
that's just because Iman valani will
this movie into Success Through a
commitment to have a blast in every
scene the MCU needs more True Believers
like her Marvel's best days are ahead of
it now why do I use the word fun and not
good well I say fun not through gritted
teeth but as a sigh of relief because
Marvel Studios needs more fun it's at
its best when it plays around with its
characters allows them to be their
authentic selves and makes us laugh it's
just been a while since I felt that way
while watching an MCU movie when you
look at the Marvels as Kamala Khan's MCU
Dream Team Up come to life this film
sings as an Avenger stands fanfiction
which is both a beautiful thing but also
at times an off-putting virtue I suspect
the Marvel's will be the most polarizing
MCU film ever made thanks to a very
silly media narrative that the franchise
is on life support and was on this film
to resuscitate it anyway some stuff
works some stuff doesn't so let's break
it down and by the way the best way to
support what we're doing here at new
rockstars is to grab a Flur and shirt
available at nerd r. shot okay what
works Iman volani as Kamala Khan steps
up in this film with a confidence and a
charm that I haven't seen a newcomer
bring to an MCU film since Tom Holland
and Captain America Civil War she's that
good it's like she was made for this she
carries the cast like when you watch the
movie just watch Iman in every scene she
is having the time of her life in every
take whether it's rocking out on aladana
hitting her stunts with some holy [__]
enthusiasm and bringing the VFX to life
with proper weight and disgust and pain
that most MCU actors just kind of shrug
at as a true Marvel nerd Iman volani
delivers a delightfully goofy comic book
movie this is how it should feel I think
it's not just her the entire Khan family
and their bits with Nick Fury are the
heart of this film Samuel L Jackson is
back to form perfect as Nick Fury in
this film so much so that you almost
forget secret Invasion happened as a
better film than 2019s Captain Marvel
the Marvels smartly heightens the
flerkens to an insane twist that makes
for the film's best scene lovers of cats
and musical theater will be thrilled I
suspect that alad will be some viewers
love and thunder screaming goats but you
know what it totally worked for me and
when it comes to MCU lore and World
building it has an astonishing
mid-credit scene and cameos and tie-ins
that will have Marvel fans sufficiently
a buzz now what misses honestly a lot
the energy that Iman valani brings as
Kamala Khan is just not matched by Brie
Larson as Carol Danvers or Tiana Paris
as Monica Rambo both of them are
amazingly talented actresses whose
characters this studio has just dragged
through muddled Back stories told in
other people's titles like I loved
Monica Rambo's introduction in W
Division and Monica's relationship with
her mother Maria in that series is
really the only emotional core that we
can grasp onto for her in this film she
doesn't have much of a relationship with
Kamala Khan and her beef with Carol
amounts to very little meanwhile I blame
Marvel Studios for throwing Carol
Danvers in a half dozen post credit
scenes in which Bri Larson often had no
idea what title she was shooting a scene
for other than Avengers endgame I don't
think Marvel Studios has ever had that
strong of a grasp on what makes Carol
daners a Great Character Kelly suconic
reconceived Carol Danver in her 2011
reboot as a hero who always gets back up
even when she gets knocked down but
unlike Steve Rogers who says I can do
this all day as he gets back up Carol
gets back up with a [__] you and the
only time I think we've seen that is
when Thanos headbutted Carol in Avengers
endgame and she didn't Flinch in this
movie I sense a [__] you from brie
Larsson but really it's toward the
studio for saddling her with unclear
attitudes toward her co-stars and toward
her past and generally a severe lack of
character development thanks to Harry's
for sponsoring this video if you've ever
tried buying a razor you've experienced
Choice paralysis that feeling of having
too many options and having no way of
picking one razor over another the best
way around it in my opinion is just use
hares Harry's is a perfect balance of
quality and affordability other blades
are more expensive than Harry's but
they're charging more because they can
not because they should Harry's sells
their blades at a factory direct price
and it's the same price for everybody
there's no pink tax you're not paying
more for packaging or marketing or
anything like that you are pain for what
you're getting which is a quality razor
and Harry is able to do this because
their blades are made in their own
Factory in Germany where they've been
making blades for 100 years you don't
need a middleman to get a great shave
you need a great razor click the link in
the description below to get a $113
Harry's trial set for just $5 and see
for yourself the interplanetary crisis
created by Dar Ben in this film presents
fascinating implications for the
politics in the astrophysics of the MCU
but it's all rested on the shoulders of
an unforgettable villain that zie Ashton
works so hard to bring texture to but we
spend far too long watching her do
things in this movie with no sense of
her objective structurally the First Act
of this film is kind of a mess which is
fun for the cosmic entanglement
slapstick humor but disorienting as a
narrative experience but wait Voss I
thought you said you like this movie I
did but if I brush over the stuff that I
didn't like about it you wouldn't
believe me when I say that I really
really like Camala and the flerkens they
are that good that they make up for
these other shortcomings but many will
see the Marvels as proof in their minds
that Marvel Studios is on the decline so
is Marvel dead I have to say that I find
these headlights to be so funny because
many of them even make sweeping
statements about YouTube views for
Marvel content being lower than usual
even for good titles like Loki even on
big channels like new rockstars I got to
clear a few things up here folks New
Rock Stars lowkey season 2 coverage is
doing fine for us like we're not
sweating over here you should all know
that the numbers that you see on a
YouTube channel or a podcast Network or
a website covering movie news only
reflect that Outlet's success at
covering that news and their connection
with their audience and not the health
of the franchise itself asking Marvel is
dead is really just a popular way at the
moment to boost short-term engagement by
playing into fan anxiety now I don't
fault anyone for doing that but it's not
the whole picture the reality is any
other Hollywood studio right now would
love to trade places with Marvel and if
you're seeing lower performance on
Marvel films it's not the result of
Marvel fatigue it's a result of
franchise fatigue all movie studios are
pumping out sequels spin-offs that fans
didn't really ask for Indiana Jones 5
Hunger Games prequel fast X Aquaman 2 a
Flash movie that kills the spiderverse
and brings back Clooney folks the
fatigue runs deeper than Marvel but the
state of the industry is looking bright
Barbie Oppenheimer Mario Five Nights at
Freddy's all of these were big event
films and IP unexplored on film that
fans were curious about even pixars
Elemental a movie that the trades wrode
off when it supposedly bombed at the
beginning of the summer totally rallied
throughout the summer for fans curious
about what this interesting weird
concept was and ended up being a huge
success so I just think it's silly to
say that Marvel is dead in a year with
huge successes from Loki from Spider-Man
across the spiderverse and from
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 the
Marvel Brand is alive and well it's all
about the Optics folks if Disney and
other Studios just paid their talent
what they were asking for sooner we
would by now have a Deadpool 3 trailer
and a Fantastic 4 announcement and no
one would be asking if Marvel was dead
we would know that with Marvel's biggest
names coming home the mcu's best days
are clearly ahead of it now before I get
to my final thoughts and where I rank
the Marvels a few reminders my breakdown
of the post credit scenes and the way
this movie ends and how it moves the
ball forward in the MCU are coming to
the channel on Thursday we are going to
put a spoiler-free thumbnail on that
video as we customarily do but early
next week we are going to update the
packaging when our spoiler window ends
and you will see a different thumbnail
on it so if you care about what happens
in this movie but you're not planning on
seeing it opening weekend yet you insist
on living on social media anyways with
zero filters it's your own fault if you
gets spoiled also new Rockstar seem by
seen breakdown of the Easter eggs in
this movie is coming Saturday after we
get through our breakdown of the Loki
finale the Loki breakdown coming Friday
joining me for our breakdown of the
Marvels will be special guest Jessica
Clemens who also saw the movie last
night and has her own hot takes of the
movie and if you live in the LA area and
want to come talk about this movie with
us in person we are doing a live show at
brain dead Studios on Thursday November
16th ticket info in the description okay
my final thoughts and ranking the
Marvels is not a great film but it is a
lot of fun and it is worth seeing alone
for Kamala Khan among MCU movies that
have come out since 2021 I rank it right
in the middle above Quanto Mania but
beneath wakand forever just because wak
forever was a better film in its
performances it's themes its production
design its music even if it had some
real low lows and so that you can all
get the full context of where I think
Marvel is at right now here's where I
think the Marvel's ranks among all MCU
Titles since 2021 including the Disney
plus titles oh God you're going to yell
at me in the comments over how I ranked
all this stuff and I don't care it may
change over time but this is how I'm
ranking it right now in November 2023
but let us know in the comments below
whether you plan on seeing the Marvel's
opening night opening weekend next week
or when it hits streaming or never and
if you already saw the movie where does
it rank for you support us by getting a
flirt insur at nerd r. shop subscribe to
all three channels in the new rockstars
Network you can follow me at eaos and I
will see you next time bye
[Music]
everybody